okay so we're to come around here here
is that tilt of your body you see okay
and then you just
accelerate you
see got it okay now use your athleticism
that we train and just run out of
[Music]
it every single
time
you see okay so
somewhere I have to start to add
differences so instead of cutting here
I'm going to start to rotate this this
way you see
back and as I do that my body is going
to go this way you feel
that
so not
[Music]
here so here is the
top Force working on your
head and here is the bottom Force
working on your leg but you're going to
go I I'll do it without Bing me you're
going to go this
way you
maybe if you want to see over
here my hand not going to go
here my hand is going to go this
way so if we say run out of it
why can't you run out of
it so Kos n is here
see again is
here there not on my question but my is
this
into that
leg
okay here you see how you have then you
go like this look where you are stay
there stay exactly there don't move your
spine don't push forward just relax just
relax let me go don't move don't move
don't
move move your
arms you're pretty PR much standing
straight up you see that okay make a
fighting stance with your hands look
okay so you went like this and you got
him down then you bring him back to that
face and he's perfectly upright again
okay you you have to tilt him he's going
to he's going to go knock back this
[Music]
way
this
way okay and then what am I going to do
step behind my that's right cuz this is
just an acceleration throw step out of
itep out of it every
time there you
go yeah
[Music]
so here is one part of the toxy
tury and here is the other
part and then don't don't make him go
that way start to spin him let's lift
this start to spin him got it
[Music]
he make him spin